distances between objects and space are
often so staggering that the human mind
is barely able to fully appreciate them
sometimes even light takes thousands of
years on end to travel from one object
to another
however among myriads of stellar systems
scattered across the vast expanses of
the universe there is only one that may
be truly called closest to us
there are three stars mutually bound by
invisible threads of gravitation that
lie comparatively nearby by space
standards and naturally attract our
closest attention
so what is the alpha centauri system
like
[Music]
the first in outer space
the earth has been emitting structured
radio signals into space for around 100
years now
the radio noise from the earth reached
dozens of other stellar systems long ago
including arcturus lying 37 light years
away from us and dow de baron which is
roughly 65 light years away
besides our radio signals may be heard
on the surfaces of a great number of
potentially habitable exoplanets like
cross-128b or gliese 667cc
still the triple stellar system of alpha
centauri remains the closest neighbor of
the sun which automatically makes it the
first obvious candidate for the
destination of the first ever
interstellar flight
alpha centauri is known to be a multiple
stellar system made up of three
components two of the larger ones are
relatively close to each other seen with
the naked eye they appear to be a single
source of light
the two components follow a slightly
elongated orbit around the common mass
center which takes around 80 years to
complete
the maximal distance between the stars
may reach 35 astronomical units with the
minimal distance reaching 11.2
astronomical units
as for the distance between these
objects and the sun it is reportedly
4.36 light years
the most massive the largest and the
brightest component in the system is
dubbed alpha centauri a
this is a main sequence star with a mass
of about 108 percent that of the sun
its radius is reportedly 1.22 times that
of our sun even though the surface
temperature and the spectral class of
alpha centauri a are close to those of
our star it emits one and a half times
as much energy
there are no confirmed exoplanets in the
environs of this star
however while the star was being
observed in the infrared in 2021 some
evidence was found of there being a
planet-like object close by
according to preliminary estimates its
mass may be anything from 9 to 35 earth
masses and its radius may measure 3.3 to
7 times that of our planet
1.1 astronomical units away from its
parent star the hypothetical celestial
body completes a full orbit around it
within roughly a year
additional observations are called for
to verify the data which can be done
with the help of either the james webb
telescope or else earth-based
observatories
the second component of the system is
called alpha centauri b or ptolemon and
it also falls into the class of main
sequence stars
however its mass is 10 percent less than
that of the sun and its radius measures
only 86 percent or so that of the sun
ptoleman is also slightly cooler than
our star its surface temperature is
reportedly
5260 kelvin or slightly lower than 5000
degrees celsius
with these factors combined the
celestial object has an orange hue and
its luminosity is on average twice as
low as that of our sun
incidentally alpha centauri b emits a
lot more energy in the x-ray range
compared with other objects of its class
besides the star is peculiar for its
temper and there are bright flares and
ejections to be seen on its surface
no confirmed exoplanets have been
detected near this star either
in 2012 a group of astronomers from the
geneva observatory put forward a
suggestion that there was a planet very
close to it whose orbital period was
around 12 days and whose radius measured
slightly less than that of the earth the
suggestion was made based on four years
of observation of the star's proper
motion
however three years later a mathematical
error was detected to have been made in
the course of data processing and so the
idea of there being a planet was found
to be erroneous
the third component of the system is a
stark contrast to the first two it is a
red dwarf with a mass approximately 12
percent that of the sun
its size is about seven times smaller
than that of the sun its surface
temperature is only slightly higher than
3000 kelvin and its luminosity is just a
measly 0.17 percent that of the sun
of all the components of the alpha
centauri system it is this dim space
object that is the closest one to the
sun lying 4.25 light years away from it
this is what earned it its name proxima
centauri which is latin for closest
besides the object is getting nearer and
nearer thus in 26
700 years it will be only a bit more
than three light years away
still this star cannot be seen from the
earth on account of its slow luminosity
proxima is noticeably far from its two
companions in the stellar system
this distance is currently around 13 000
astronomical units or 0.21 light years
but in the next 300 000 years it is
expected to gradually shrink to just
four thousand one hundred astronomical
units
it takes proxima 547
000 years to orbit around the system's
common mass center
unlike its two larger neighbors the
proxima centauri system boasts two
confirmed exoplanets as well as at least
one hypothetical object
besides studies of the star in the
infrared allowed scientists to assume
that there is a dust string and probably
a great number of small celestial
objects like asteroids or comets
the first planet in the system proxima
centauri b was detected in 2016 by the
radial velocities method
four years later in 2020 it was
confirmed by spectrographic studies with
the help of the largest earth-based
telescope on our planet vlt the very
large telescope
according to the updates the exoplanet
lies 0.05 astronomical units away from
its parent star and it takes it roughly
11 earth days to complete a full orbit
estimates show that the planet's mass is
10 to 20 percent bigger than that of the
earth and its radius measures about 1.3
times that of our planet
mathematical modeling revealed that
proxima centauri b gets about one and a
half times as little thermal energy from
its star as does the earth from the sun
its average temperature is
234 kelvin or 39 degrees celsius below
zero which means that hypothetically
there could be liquid water in some
areas on the planet
as the celestial body is extremely close
to its host star however it is likely to
be tidally locked so it faces the star
with one on the same side
a dense atmosphere could compensate for
sharp contrasts in temperatures which
are inevitable in such conditions but
just like any other red dwarves proxima
centauri is often seen to eject stellar
matter also ionizing radiation flares
are observed
it is assumed that such activity
gradually destroys the atmosphere of the
closest objects
a powerful magnetic field that could be
encompassing proxima centauri b could
offer some protection against the
destructive process but chances that
there is any magnetic field there are
thin
in the year 2020 another planet was
confirmed to exist in the system
a space object dubbed proxima centauri c
lies roughly one and a half astronomical
units away from the center of the system
its orbital cycle is slightly over five
years
as for the object's mass it may be six
to eight times that of the earth but its
radius hasn't been estimated at the time
this video is posted
depending on its size meanwhile the
exoplanet will fall either in the
category of many neptunes or super
earths
as proxima centauri sea lies quite a big
distance away from its parent star its
temperature is remarkably low about 39
kelvin or
234 degrees celsius below zero
according to some observations the
planet may have a ring system whose
radius is roughly five times that of
jupiter
also based on the latest data from vrt a
remarkably small exoplanet is expected
to line
0.029 astronomical units away from its
parent star whose mass is about 25
percent that of the earth
if it does exist and if this isn't
another measurement error a year on this
planet lasts about five earth days and
the surface temperature there could be
360 kelvin or 87 degrees celsius
whether this space object is really
there or not remains an open question
and additional confirmations are called
for
alpha centauri has been listening to our
radio signals for over a hundred years
now
but the 40 trillion kilometers of space
vacuum between us are too overwhelming
for us to cover at this point
it takes light over four years to get
there but for humans such speeds are
still in the realm of fancy
even today's swiftest state-of-the-art
spacecraft would need tens of thousands
of years to cover this distance
however application of advanced
technologies could theoretically greatly
reduce travel time since the very dawn
of space exploration projects of a great
number of spacecraft have been suggested
that hypothetically would have been able
to negotiate interstellar distances
nevertheless not a single one of them
has been actually designed
most of these would-be missions were
forgotten but one is still under active
consideration
this is the breakthrough starshot
program which implies sending as many as
a thousand microprobes to proxima
centauri as soon as in the first half of
this century
they will not measure over a centimeter
in size and special thin and durable
sails are planned to be created to aid
the probes along
the sails will be blown out as it were
by impulses of a highly powerful
earth-based laser estimates show that an
interstellar probe like that is going to
be leaving the solar system at a speed
roughly 20 percent that of the speed of
light with the overall travel time
around 20 years
after that it will take another five
years or so for the data collected by
the mission to reach the earth
remote stars may currently be out of
bounds but we can observe them
apart from james webb which is already
transmitting data to the earth from its
orbit the launch of another orbital
telescope ptoleman is scheduled as soon
as in 2023
even though this space complex is not as
advanced as james webb in terms of its
technical characteristics it has its
edge in its studies ptoleman will be
targeting specifically alpha centauri
and its nearest stars
in spite of all difficulties the secrets
of the universe are slowly giving way to
our tenacity and every day space is
getting closer
let's keep in touch
[Music]
[Music]
you